our first question today is from
Jacqueline in Detroit struggling with my
metamours journey I started out and when
I found you guys it was like a breath of
fresh air and now I seem to be really
struggling with putting this into youth
100% of the time most of this lens to
consumerism so I believe that I am
shopping compulsively and I don't know
how to stop necessarily you know the
IKEA monologue from Fight Club when they
talk about this couch like once I get
this couch I'll be fine or what lamp
defines me that's totally me and I don't
know how to stop it because reading
about it or listening to you guys I'm
totally on board philosophically but
then when it comes to putting it into
practice I have these moments of
weakness where I just revert back and I
do not know what to do so Ryan tell me
what you think about this analogy I was
thinking about this so so Jacqueline's
saying you know she's talking about
shopping compulsively she can't apply
applied minimalism 100% and and she's
struggling to like sort of feel complete
as if the next purchase is going to make
us feel complete and in the the analogy
or maybe metaphor here of dieting I
often think about there isn't there
probably is not a perfect diet for
anyone although it's highly individual
right but minimalism isn't sort of the
anorexic equivalent of dieting right my
partner Rebecca she she's a dietitian
and a nutritionist and so she has
clients that she works with in several
of whom struggle with anorexia or
bulimia and she's worked with a lot of
college students back when she was at
the University for a decade who
struggled with those and that's not an
that's not a diet that is a disorder the
same way that hoarding or OCD can be a
disorder I have OCD and and minimalism
helped me sort of keep that under
control in a way because it's been
easier not to
- there are two sides of the sort of OCD
spectrum I finished watching that show
that you recommended during the added
value um evil genius oh yeah
and there are several hoarders in there
and and that's just that that's a type
of OCD in a way where it's like
compulsively holding on to things right
and and I think about OCD or minimalism
that is not that they're not the same
thing people often mistake minimalism
too with having nothing living as a
ascetic and III don't want Jacqueline to
think that like well I I can't apply
minimalism 100% of the time so I can't
apply it minimalism at all I don't think
it's about I don't think it's about
stopping shopping because she said how
do I stop it's about figuring out what
things are appropriate to buy yeah it's
not right there uh yeah I see what
you're saying it to me it sounds like
she is using shopping as a pacifier and
I think the way I interpreted the
question was is how do I stop using
shopping as a pacifier to stop those
impulses so yeah I agree with you 100%
we do not have to stop shopping it's not
about you know becoming a minimalist and
never buying anything again or becoming
a minimalist and buying only used items
or like you said there isn't this this
there is not this totalitarian set of
rules that each minimalist has to abide
by just like diet right the writer it's
not well here's the diet you must follow
their rhyme that will work better for
others that for certain people than
other people right and especially like
say Jacqueline's got you know a husband
and six kids like what they buy as a
family is gonna be much different than
what Mariah and I buy as a family sure
so yeah just blanketing any type of
rules um I don't think it's going to
really I don't think it's gonna help
Jacqueline here I think I think what's
gonna help Jacqueline is is her finding
better habits to replace shopping with
yeah
so shopping as a dude it's tempting for
me as one of the minimalists living in
Los Angeles it's like when I'm bored I
have totally had I'm gonna go to the
Apple store because now it's three
blocks from my place right it's not you
know used to be three hours drive
through two states to get there how do I
get this bouquet now it's three blocks
from my my place and everything you know
I think the last I um I lost I lost I
lost my air pods so I went to replace
him I almost lost mine twice in the last
two weeks dude I found them both times I
really hope that someone just like
picked him up and they're using them but
like my fears that they fell out out and
like now they're in the the cushion of
this like it buried in this couch and
this Airbnb I was staying at anyway I
went to the Apple store this was a
couple months ago and went in there to
buy the air pods and dude like it was so
hard for me to like walk out with just
the air pods but but my time kind of
going down a rabbit so good so what what
did you see there that your it was like
oh dude they had like they had really
good Bluetooth speakers they had you
know the iPhone acts they had iPhone 10
they had cases and protectors and
bluetooth gadgets that will hook to your
phone and computer and I mean it's just
like this this world of convenience new
computer that they yeah that they offer
you at at the at the Apple Store yeah
it's funny I I was listening to someone
recently they were talking about how
they went into the Apple Store and they
actually they were shocked because the
the pros Duncan Trussell he said that he
went in there I like to replace his
computer and the person Apple was like
what are you using it for and he's like
well I you know I write on it and I
added a little bit of audio and they're
like well this the computer you have is
only four years old it's fine for what
you're doing right now is a reason you
want to upgrade you know I was like my
mind was blown that this company who
sells more products than any other
company on the face of the earth can say
hey maybe you don't need the new product
right now and that that's a good thing
now it was just it's not the company
said that was one individual who said
that I don't know if that's their
corporate ethos or something right
but it made me realize like I anytime I
go to Apple store like I had a AppleCare
issue a few months ago and I had to
bring something in there and I
immediately looked at like oh look at
the shiny new MacBook I mean I've got my
my MacBook Pro or whatever the hell it
is the the my laptops I've had you know
we bought them the same time 2014 maybe
I don't
yeah it was yeah it was was when we took
Shawn on yeah so twenty thirteen or
fourteen whenever I was yeah and and we
all have the same computer basically and
I bet I go in there and I'm like oh that
one is shinier than mine and look at the
the keys on it are slightly different
it's more aerodynamic aerodynamic am I
gonna throw this thing so so for me man
like the way the way that I avoid like I
guess acting on that impulse to go shop
or to go even a window shop man like
that's tempting dude I mean there are
there's a plethora of places to shop
here in Los Angeles and window shopping
even that that's just gonna that's going
to develop the desire even more it adds
more temptation right exactly so for me
like I I try to stay as active as
possible whether it's working out
whether it's going on walks
whether it's mountain biking whether
it's surfing whether it's going to your
house to watch a movie yeah I try to
fill my time with as many that extra
time I should say I try to fill my extra
time up with as many either active
things or the communal things where I'm
experiencing something with with a
friend or with the community but but yes
sitting around and in doing nothing of
being bored watch especially watching TV
like that is that right there is going
to make you want to shop more yeah so
here's a here's what I would recommend
for Jacqueline is if she wants to curb
this desire
first and foremost Jacqueline get as
many advertisements out of your life as
possible so
how does jacqueline do that get rid of
cable get rid of it or watch only the
stuff you record and fast fast-forward
through the commercials yeah uh pay the
extra three four five however many
dollars it costs to get the ad free
version of whatever it is that you're
using to entertain yourself pay that
extra a little bit with YouTube I find
that yes premium and it's like twelve
bucks a month and it's the best twelve
dollars I spend every month absolutely
because I there is not a single ad ever
unless someone tries now people are
doing the sponsored things inside like
if we were doing ads on this podcast all
of a sudden you like our YouTube channel
we could be making lots of money if we
had ads turn on our youtube I don't know
but it doesn't align with our ethos so
we have those turned off so even if you
watch our videos on the free version you
don't get served up ads right unless
YouTube does something without our
permission so right alright but-but-but
Jaqueline think about all the ways that
you take in advertisements using that if
you're not using an ad blocker for
anyone out there if you're not using an
ad blocker it's free yeah just Google
free ad blocker and pick the first one
that comes up that's what I did in fact
Sean in the show I don't know what the
name of my ad blockers but I'll figure
it out before the end of the show and
Sean if you could put that into the show
notes put an ad blocker under your
computer but Jacqueline all the
advertisements that you see they are
affecting you they are seating in your
conscience they are making you want to
buy things they are giving you they're
adding to this impulse that you already
have they're playing to that impulse so
so the first step is get rid of as many
advertisements as possible yeah and the
thing you talked about with replacing I
really like that right so so it's not
about stopping just stopping because
then it's gonna be hard it's like you
just stopped shopping and they not I'll
stand here stoic Lee and do nothing well
that that's not reasonable cuz you that
now you're just gonna ruminate about the
things you're not purchasing so I think
it's about replacing and so some
questions ask there's what can I replace
this with right because shopping is an
activity so what are the activities it
might be dodgeball it might be hiking it
might be you're going to the aquarium
with your kids III don't know what your
life looks like but what do you want it
to look like and then absolutely maybe
it's meditating
exactly so that meditation alone will
help with those impulses yes
although meditating alone if you're just
doing that you'll probably ruminate and
at first and so I find activities that
help you stay focused and then peppering
in the meditation be sure will be really
helpful and then and so meditation is a
definitely more meaningful experience as
shopping we both agree with that right
yeah so maybe the question to ask then
if you're getting ready to go shopping
is what is a more meaningful experience
than this and if you ask yourself that
question you're gonna that's a better
question you're gonna start getting
better answers yeah Sean also please put
in the show notes the links to the
meditations that we did for the 10%
happier app yeah I will the 10% half of
your app and then if you are a patreon
supporter we have a meditation on there
we have one meditation or on our patreon
page we'll probably do some more in the
future as well yeah they're just like
two three
what's a long as when we did five
minutes maybe yeah nine minutes or
something like that yeah that that is
just a meditation on not consuming
anti-consumerism meditation so okay so
that that's another thing Jacqueline can
do is find something to change your
state when you get that impulse so maybe
you want to go buy the latest greatest
stylish lamp and you get that impulse
stop yourself listen to a three-minute
meditation whether it's Josh and ice
meditation or someone else's it doesn't
matter change your state somehow stop
for three minutes to reconsider and if
you still feel and go buy the lamp
afterwards okay great change your
approach next time but you got to find
some way to to interrupt that impulse
that you get I like that podcast Sean if
we could get that other meditation we
recorded for then and put it on our
patreon feed that way we'll have two
meditations up there both meditations
that we did so you can find those on his
10% half of your app as well and then if
your patreon supporter you can find them
on our patreon page you just click on
there's different tags you just click
the meditation tag we'll put it on there
shortly after this episode goes up so
within a week of this episode going up
what we'll put the the other one the
other anti-consumerism meditation up
there for you and a couple other things
i recommend ryan here just recommend
thinking about really is that you'll
never be complete right that
that couch that you buy will not make
you more complete it will not make you a
better human being
ideally though if we buy the right
things for our life they will enhance
they'll amplify they'll augment our
experience of life sure you came over to
my house we had movie night this this
past weekend me you and backs and Mariah
and and we sat on a couch is we didn't
sit on just hardwood floors or or so
that that couch augmented our experience
for the evening
we drank water out of glasses instead of
putting our head under the faucet right
we maybe you guys did we hypocrite we
who we ate dinner off of plates yes
instead of just pouring the food onto
the table no of course of course we need
some stuff in and those things augmented
our experience however let's say I
bought more plates and I had seven sets
of plates at my house that wouldn't have
improved our evening at all in fact it
probably just got in the way because it
also I'm thinking about which plate
should we use this this evening should I
break out the fine china tonight I like
this idea Rob and Kristen Bell they they
always use the fine china they got some
really nice China for their wedding gift
or some anniversary thing or whatever so
even our regular just normal breakfast
meals they'll break out the really
because they like use the nice things as
opposed to just storing them long term
yeah use the things that you have if
you're using them if they serve a
purpose to bring you joy then great also
the author Christina cook she talks
about will put a link to her website she
also has a book called the joy of
missing out it's sort of the the
opposite of the fear of missing out mmm
it's the the joy Jomo yeah yeah it's
Jomo and if you can assume oh that's
that that's yeah yeah instead of FOMO
just so we all have the fear of missing
out because it's like how can I be more
complete if I just buy the thing this
thing this thing I'll be more complete
and if not I'm missing out
I didn't even check the tweet I need to
check this and it's the reason I don't
have social media on my phone it's cuz I
always feel like I'm going to be like I
gotta check the next thing what do
people say to my Instagram post and
and like I just get caught up in the
missing out and and so maybe there's a
joy of missing out that Christina crook
talks about but I think there's a step
in between what I would call wome oh
okay the welcoming of missing Alice and
maybe you don't get the joy yet but you
just bask in the fact that yes you pause
and you let out the breath haha I am
this now I had missing out it's all
right yeah I'm gonna welcome this it's
okay yeah because no matter what even if
you get that couch and you get all the
knickknacks is gonna make your life
perfect it's not gonna be perfect no and
you're still you're still missing out on
99.999% of everything else that's out
there and letting go is really hard
right so we went through the whole thing
of what have you let go of recently
that's that's a hard exercise and it
gets easier the more you let go but how
about this not buying something as your
future self letting go in advance
yeah or you're letting go of that
impulse yeah yeah you can tweet that
show that's a minimal maximum for you
not buying something is your future self
letting go and in advance so it's like
saving money now so you don't have the
interest compounds this is sort of like
reverse interest in a way you don't have
to let go of the thing you don't buy
yeah and and so think about it that way
is do I really want to have to deal with
this later do I want to deal with the
packaging and the charging of the thing
and do I want to have to deal with once
this thing is not serving its purpose or
maybe it's never actually gonna serve
its purpose I just got really excited it
was an aspirational purchase ya know
here at the Apple store and you're like
oh I bet I could use the Bluetooth thing
and the cable and maybe that case will
do this and then then you're like but
when I really think about it oh that's
what someone else would get from it
that's not might not be what I would
actually give yeah exactly
another thing that Jacqueline said that
stands out to me she said you know she's
bought in you know with the philosophy
of minimalism but having a hard time
acting on it you know I thought I
started thinking about like I used to be
bought into the idea of exercise I used
to be bought into the idea of healthy
eating and you can be bought into an
idea if you do not take action
then it is just an idea and I think
Jacqueline should look at this as diet
or exercise like what what can you do to
start taking massive action towards
living a more simple life and we're
gonna talk about hearing a little bit
kind of some stuff that we consider
before we buy before we buy things and
Jacqueline you can use you know that the
things that we consider or you can make
up your own structure but I know when it
comes to diet I have to have a structure
to my diet yeah it's a very simple
structure with exercise I have to have
structure with that like Mariah and I we
get to the gym where we try to workout
not even try it we do we work out at
least five days a week hands down at
least for 45 minutes five days a week
this week it'll be seven days this week
right yeah it's awesome n in like that
structure is what will help us to
continue to live a healthy lifestyle and
and continue to be in that exercise
routine and I'll tell you as soon as
like we go on tour dude I am NOT gonna
be able to work out seven days a week
and when I come back it's gonna be
harder for me to get back into that
structure I think you will be able to
die I think since you set up this
structure and you feel really good about
it it may not be the same workout right
but you can hit the elliptical for
forty-five minutes as soon as we get to
the Hampton Inn or wherever we're sure
yeah I guess what I'm saying though is
that sometimes the structure will fall
apart a little bit yeah and Mariah and I
we have to really really rely on those
boundaries we set up for ourselves if we
don't then we will quickly just be on
the outside looking at the idea of
exercise instead of actually exercising
absolutely
you